the beijing winter olympics hit by
deluge of complaints from athletes
freezing conditions they're complaining
about
[ __ ] it's the winter olympics
you can't complain about freezing
conditions
if you do in
the winter olympics
that's like
being at a hooker house and complaining
that
somebody's touching your neck
okay
you can't
you know what i'm saying like they got
what else they saying uh
they've been served the same thing five
days in a row for breakfast lunch and
dinner [ __ ] that's china
have you been to china i was on a train
in china a girl opened up a bag of
bird feet
and ate them
and guess what
she was a [ __ ] hot chick
so you're in a place where hot [ __ ]
is eating
bird feets
do you know that
did you google china [ __ ]
go get find something in your house
that's falling apart
that's china dog
that's china
okay that's what we sold america for
so don't be shocked when you go to china
and [ __ ] gets
china
[ __ ] gonna get china in china
the big air ski jump at the olympics
looks like it's set next to a nuclear
power plant
it is dog
it don't look like it it is baby
get that huff off the air baby that's
god trying to gas you up son
if you think you could jump far regular
imagine if you got that nuclear in your
son you might jump your way all the way
into a [ __ ] dirty bat cage baby
it's china dog
china going to china
you can't be in china and be shocked
when [ __ ] gets china
come on man damn
behind the skiers launching themselves
at the 60 meter high foot ramp are
furnaces tall chimney stacks and cooling
towers yeah
uh
yeah [ __ ] that scenery [ __ ]
that's scenery
dude that is damn scenery bro
bro i remember one time when i was
growing up dude we had a bike ramp right
and the best place for it
in our area was right by this
pedophile's house
which he got to sit there and watch us
you know he's sitting there over there
like he had a damn delicatessen bro
he picking [ __ ] future touches out of
his teeth
but
that's the location of the deal
so you can't be shot man if you go to
china and [ __ ] gets chinatic
you can't be shocked man
y'all complaining too much y'all
supposed to be olympians
bruh
[Music]
y'all could handle this if y'all
olympians y'all could handle it
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one